un attimo che devo capire chi capita
qualche [ __ ] lo sapevo
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa dj ed oggi siamo tornati su
altra scala vr i nostri ragazzi che io
ero sotto il letto come come faccio ogni
notte praticamente da quando ho giocato
e quindi direi che possiamo continuare a
quel punto si ritrova adesso giuro che
ti lancio una di quelle matera state in
testa che non è mi cerca ancora cioè io
direi su s s sì sì ce l'ho fatta no no
cazzo cazzo allora sei stronzo ragazzi
non so come uscire qui non so come è
fottutamente uscirà di questo stronzo
non si apre niente non si apre niente
caffè
no no sì sì sì no no paga non ce la farò
mai
non ce la farò fottutamente mai io non
ho idea di dove si andrà eccola qui
finalmente a mezz'ora per trovare
sottoposto [ __ ] sale senta c'era
un tizio brutto prima lei che non si
vede
senti il segreto lo dici al mio amico ok
non mi rompere i [ __ ] perché batman
quale che poi perché parla in inglese
l'unico che parla in inglese lui c'era
cosa ma a me non importa se possiamo
andare avanti senza farci stuprare ecco
le chiavi le chiavi chiave delle manette
perfetto poi farti cazzi tuoi per favore
già c'è l'altro che [ __ ] almeno
tu mi odia avanti più ragazzi tanto è
cieco sbatte alla quale non parte la
pancia sulla porta e bellissimo nemica
non vede la porta di milano meda la
vista torniamo indietro prima che torni
quella merda di prima
non voglio girare non voglio girarmi
non voglio girarmi e mi giro lo stesso
non vedo un cazzo non importa saliti
sull i sali mio dio
perfetto allora non vi è lo sapevo che
c'era stato aperto st porta che prima
non era aperta ma noi alla fine manette
veloce ragazzi ci siamo ci ho messo anni
ma ci siamo
vediamoli andare avanti basta basta dopo
questo sono già morto ve lo dico a
fatemi chiudere la porta per l'amor di
dio prima che entri qualcuno di
spiacevole fatemi andare avanti perché
succeda qualsiasi cosa di brutto come se
non fosse già successo niente scendervi
che buio io qua dentro non ci metterò
mai neanche il naso porca [ __ ] fatemi
andare avanti senza che giunti ragazzi
c'è un tizio svenuto è andata in volta
poverino cioè uscita ho trovato il mio
nuovo obiettivo devono riuscire a capire
ma io così quasi chiuderei la porta
nada e scherza fatemi andare ugualmente
per poi sembra che sia scortese non un
attimo che devo capire che capiti
qualche a buttare lo sapevo lo sapevo
brutto stronzo mica sembri sembri
sembrino è la carne mia
si vabbè magari ma compra qualcosa dal
macellaio brutto stronzo di merda
togliti dai [ __ ] che ha fatto ci ha
ripensato e ripensata ragazzi
tu sei lì sì ma zio fatti la polizia a
cuocere
ah ho capito allora prima mi cuoce e poi
no vabbè ma c'è un passaggio se idiota
card apri apri stronzo
hai visto dragon ball 10 anni per cosa
prima niente cazzo cazzo
ok allora abbiamo fatto un po di casino
nel frattempo non o eri mio così impari
a uccidere te prende prima di cuocerlo
brutto stronzo
buongiorno a rega fatemi capire un
attimo chiesto tizio perché prima non è
uno sicuramente molto bello ma che non
ci tengo a vederlo in faccia parlare
dall uscita grazie a dio è chiusa o mio
dio non me l'aspettavo vento ragazzi c'è
fra cristoforo qui che ci dà il
benvenuto presumo che io debba tornare
indietro c'è una scala qui posso andare
possa andare nei bellissimi punti dove
era caduto quel tizio o giarda mikami 8
visto cadere di di brutto forse hai
scambiato con un ascensore ci sarà una
scala ma ecco perfetto mi sembrava
strano la prossima volta mi sa che
impara a cuocere le persone prima di
mangiarne di rega ma perché devo fare
ste cose al tailleur che già è difficile
che è successo
porca [ __ ] cosa che non doveva
succedere la proprio questa per circa
0,5 secondi cielo ha avuto nel ca pranzi
siamo ancora vivi è comunque hanno
importa eccolo lì perfetto un giorno che
se solo avessi un paio di ali sarei già
uscito maledizione anno c'è qualcosa qui
che cazzo come si scusi entra qua dentro
ragazzi aiuto amico nome ci si abbassa
no forse non era quello un tasto anche
che cazzo cliccato avere un impatto
ragazzi che si sono file che passeranno
alla storia dove siamo batte ragazzi ho
fatto l'acrobata non ho neanche capito
dove siamo finiti fra che sto fatto non
dire a nessuno che sto andando di qua è
chi cazzo sono rega aprite regalo avevo
detto che sarebbe stata gran continuavo
ad altissimo quasi fuori aprite
maledetti che non siete altro
buongiorno ragazzi c'è un tizio brutto
c'è un tizio brutto che mi ha spuntato
davanti all'improvviso nome ne sono
fuori buongiorno buongiorno giorno
no non perfetto bravo maledetto prega e
colpa di fra cristoforo legale è colpa
sua donna come ho fatto a passare
ragazzi e ragazze non so dove cazzo
andarmi case mi raggiunge se mi
raggiunge solo nella merda io lo dico
non è ok
sparita la musica asperità musica ma
capraia lo sapevo che è successo mi si è
chiuso tutto mi si è chiuso già bello
così ok ok ok ok ok ragazzi siamo siamo
messi di merda non so davvero non so
dove devo andare
non so dove devo andare voglio enna dove
cazzo vado di qui lo share non ha visto
il dominio salto dove stiamo perché c'è
un materasso sporco di mestruazioni qui
era la fatica dove siamo finiti
salve ma che giornata di merda che è
questa dove stiamo andando
i quali quali qua di qua veloce salta
donna dove stiamo andando
di qua sono andati per gli prima di qua
sì sì sì sì ragazzi mi sono salvato il
culo in una maniera di fra cristoforo
finalmente sul finito di eccessi nella
vicina fatemi piscia salverà tentar non
può non può stare che cosa vedi chi sono
idiota senta non può stare
scusami tantissimo ragazzi non
disturbiamo le persone che stanno
giocando perché mi sembra mi sembra
scortese vediamo di cuore che ha prima
che succeda qualcos'altro di brutto cosa
molto probabile ci ha visto sto posto io
mar quello dell'inizio
noi siamo la sorella 3 frazione chiudilo
chiude justy prego e vabbè ma se mi fai
prendere ma gli infarti magari devo
chiudere il gas
praticamente la cazzo sta al gas tra
l'altro ragazzi questo è anche l'uscita
quindi se riesco a trovare la strada per
uscire di qua è fantastico
sarebbe fantastico ma non la troverò mai
questo e questo è certo
rispunta nessuno vero ok c'è una buona
notizia
salve io il più usato dai miei brutto
sei ragazzi non va bene non si può
grande anche perche non avevo capito che
volessi farmi del male scusami amebe
mattino non hanno se vuoi ma ma
ripensandoci fi d'azione che è meglio
sentire io vado vado di qua ok perfetto
grazie mille
cos'è sta roba 237 237
non lo so lo scopriremo più avanti
evidentemente noi io vado di qua perché
quel tizio mi fa veramente paura non
volevo dire però è così perché lampeggia
a colella 237 scommetto affanculo sé
ovunque ragazzi si no apri apri bastardo
no anno fa di questo non farmi questo no
vogliono sei pronto lo sapevo non mi
dovevo fidare di quel maledetto lo
sapevo chiudi ragazzi lo sa io lo sapevo
io ci avrei scommesso qualsiasi cosa sì
sì sì che culo che culo ok ti ho trovato
un passaggio a caso legale non so non so
neanche io come tusk ha dato questa
aperta fantastico si può raggiungerlo in
ogni momento della vita
nel caso andato poi sparisce così non so
come regalo coro a prescindere cor
magari la giungla dove cazzo andato
importante che non ce l'abbia ma
pertanto sta porta prima non l'aveva
aperta ci siamo
cosa c'è più di unique io dica dov'è
dunque non fare di carico di qua veloce
quell'altro ma non entra finito ma
perché non me ne sto zitto porca [ __ ]
si ok sul caso un top non mi chiedete
come ma ce l'ho fatta
si no vabbè però che palle veloci chiudi
più di qualsiasi cosa ma magari in tempo
per una cagata ci stanno la velocista il
tempo ai veloce dove siamo come fa quel
dio mi faccio il culo così per passare
da una stanza all'altra col disco ci
arrivano il suo come non è possibile c'è
ma mi spiegate cosa cazzo era c'è una
maledetta valvola da qualche parte per
la no ma cos'è sta roba
perché se io riuscissi a trovare una
maledetta porta dove conte porte ci sono
in stoffa buongiorno anche a lei senza
saper caso dove premi tasto sinistro per
nasconderti ragazzi basta e non c'è non
solo
no no io santissimo si chiude chiudi
come il conduttore sono no non mi sono
chiuso nella merda mi sono chiuso nella
merda nella merda
da ragazzi sono nella merda perché
l'iphone dai bastardo dai dai vieni qui
vieni ok come ho detto ragazzi aiuto
dove sto andando dove sta tanto le cure
più dvd
si ok nostro sito ci si mi sto andando
che sto andando [ __ ] a merano dove
dove sta andando male dice di qua di qua
non si sa però sapete quel cazzo non si
torna indietro
frad indietro fin qui sotto ok tagli
calmi no no no no no
allora io sono bello tu sei brutto sei
pieno di sangue non mi rompere col forti
ma forti titulo testa di minchia ragazzi
cioè vale questo ci permette di
insultare così o se n'è andato perfetto
ragazzi lo vedo a di qua mi chiama sono
deficiente allora mia madre ma si può
salire i temi dissi vi prego ditemi de
vivre non si possa vivere ma si si si si
può salire gnudi non ci credo ci siamo
ragazzi siamo ci sia o finalmente dove
non ha idea di come ci sia arrivato qui
dias room perfetto promette benissimo
regali dio ti ringrazio sì sì sì
mio dio raggiungi la radio della pena
parola come fa e modo tornando propri ma
io ci provo io vado di corsa non me ne
frega niente
ok a casa un mezzo che un cazzo se lo
vedo lo prendo a calci in faccia
piuttosto dove non lo so ok ok ok veloci
chiudi chiudi più di chi li perfetto
milioni
non so no ho visto ho visto chiude anche
questa ok forse sì che forse mi sono
salvato alcuno forse io corro non me
frega un cazzo
corro come ok ogni volta che mi sa che
non le porte in faccia lega mi prendo
male ma poi alla fine è meglio così ci
siamo si sentono di loro prima sotto la
t numero prima ragazza
ok ci soci addio santissimo tuo brutto
stronzo
mi hai fatto fare sto casino fatemi
andare avanti lega prima che intanto
perché stiamo andando di sotto
sono uscito se dio mio
siamo nel giardino però come nella kick
che cazzo ti cori tu perché è uno che
corre fermo dove vai ragazzi c'è un
tizio che core lo inseguo anche se non
lo vedo più a caso il
che è che cazzo è successo a sono
inciampata sono inciampati in una pozza
di sangue bellissimo che sarah era il
blocco dei più delle della prigione
credo che cosa ci faccia chi ce l'ha
dentro si sta allenando annunciò che
maschera mai zio un canestro mischiava
fenomeno una donna sei un genio zio è
bellissimo il fatto che sto per andare
in un posto che so già che mi divertire
un sacco insieme a tanti begli amici chi
sei tu beh birillo amico mio
allora servizi ragazzi e riconosce
bocciata da dal outlast normale soltanto
che ci tenevano rifare la loro
conoscenza invece me li devo di trovare
di nuovo porto prova cavani porta
proprio la passata di co lo stesso anche
se c'è uno nudo lo due nudi
io faccio assassin's creed sui tavoli
tipo corro oppure no di qua veloce
veloce non c'e la cia non c'è perfetto
ok ok non sono anche sono stati fermi
tra l'altro non so perché anche schifo
ragazzi dove devo andare ecco che
aspetto che è successo a ecco quello che
gioca a basket
allora amico mio io chiudo qui che ci
sono dei pervertiti ti va di giocare a
basket
non ho io io volevo soltanto giocare a
amico mio io ma non sai giocando a
basket ragazzi ritiri attesta che i
fatti che ne stravinto ok no senti per
favore ti prego titolo tante caramelle e
anche un buon dentista ma fammi passare
ma posso passare di qua posso grazie no
non posso perfetto grazie mille alla
sete stronzi voi che non perché ho
chiuso la porta e mi serviva si si come
fatto a passare grazie no no no no tu no
però tu no tu no dai veloce velox dal
carcere poiché ci dovremmo aver fatta
mio dio reagan non so non so come ho
fatto a passare non me lo chiedete non
ne ho idea si va di qua qualcosa mi dice
di sì
vediamo se riusciamo ad andare avanti
ok ok ok perfetto io vado avanti di
quanto mandavano quei tizi perché mi
sembra meno peggio ragazzo succede se si
lo siamo è aperto
fatemi chiudere st porta perché minchia
non è possibile dove dove siamo dove la
radio sì sì l'ho presa e l'ho presa
grazie a dio ma allora me 20 radio 105
il cazzo sei brutto stronzo di merda
cosa taggia no no ma save us ma
[ __ ]
ci ho messo mezza no vabbè però mica tv
a pedate guai non park non potevi so ma
chi cazzo sei riuscito a cooperare hai
finito di chiacchierare ora fuori fuori
stronzo fai un favore mori qui successo
doveva 2 cazzo va domandato è sparito
no no lui no lui ragazzino a lui tutti
ma non lui vi prego perché lo perché lui
tra tutti quelli che no no no no no no
no no no ti prego ti prego non farò
qualsiasi con i cattivi sono tanti di
quegli hamburger che sarei felice tutta
la vita ma non aprì la porta per favore
grazie mi ha ascoltato come ha fatto ad
arrivare fin qui quel male come non è
possibile
un cazzo no no no no no no no no no no
no no no l'accordo ragazzi direi che
posso concludere qui per questo episodio
giusto per lasciarvi con la suspense
perché mi piace da morire
i ragazzi io per oggi che un tool doppio
episodio come al solito ragazzi servito
è piaciuto lasciato un momento mi piace
anche all pagliari facebook come ogni
video trovate nella descrizione se non
siete vorresti scrivete noi ci rivediamo
il prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]